[Musique]
ce vendredi 27 mai cyrille melchior
président du département a distribué des
colis gourmand 30 résidants du foyer
d'accueil médicalisé d'alice verdun à la
veille de la fête des mères la
collectivité temps à rompre l'isolément
des personnes âgées en situation de
handicap hébergés dans les
établissements médico-sociaux et chez
les accueillants familiaux
le département
porte une mission essentielle c'est de
bien accompagner les personnes âgées et
parfois aussi les personnes porteuses de
handicap et dans ce cadre nous avons
voté un dispositif en commission
permanente qui veut que dans le cadre de
ce bien-être que nous recherchons eh
bien le département pourra
régulièrement mettre à disposition de
tous les établissements de l'île des
petits paquets cadeaux contenant pas des
friandises dégâts pub rebond la route ne
connais bien des petits bobos manioc les
petits bonbons safran des petites choses
qui font que ma dans la difficulté de
tous les jours face aux difficultés de
tous les jours et bien que ces personnes
résidentes aurons des moments de plaisir
des moments de bonheur et c'est ce que
nous voulons faire en sorte que le
bien-être soit une réalité quoi tous les
résidents de tous les établissements
accueillant des personnes âgées est
porteuse handicap ce sont plus de 3500
colis de produits 100% pays qui seront
distribués au sein de 51 et par les 24
foyers d'accueil
massage thérapeutique panier gourmand et
rencontres intergénérationnelles sont
prévues dans le cadre du plan bien-être
dont cette distribution est la première
opération
[Musique]